okay you seem like an adorable sweet old
lady on the outside but on the inside
on the inside you're like this this this
seething
demon you hear me ryan reynolds is
reigniting
his feud with betty white
but it's all in tribute to the golden
girl's
recent milestone betty celebrated her
99th
birthday on saturday what is your
problem got an issue with me i don't
have a problem with her she hates me and
i don't really understand why
drew turn the camera off i know you're
filming it's like the night lens captain
yeah you made it to me she's a complete
hey hey so to commemorate her special
day
ryan posted these funny moments to his
instagram stories
oh there she is
[Music]
how's america's sweetheart oh betty stop
ryan and betty co-starred in the 2009
rom-com
the proposal and they filmed this
hilarious sketch
from the set for funny or die hi betty
how are you uh brian
ryan my name is ryan get me a cup of
coffee you know my name's ryan
uh we've we've been working together for
weeks months actually
months now dan you've been a terrible
assistant that whole time
ryan captioned the videos quote we made
these
12 years ago betty turns 99 today
but she is 100 the funniest person
on the planet when betty white says she
wants a cup of coffee
you get her a cup of coffee i'm gonna
tell you exactly how it is okay you seem
like
an adorable sweet old lady on the
outside but on the inside
on the inside you're like this this this
seething
demon they just said let's bring you all
together and let's just shoot a funny
video and we did
at the time ryan gave e.t some behind
the scenes details from the sketch
and joked that there were even more
intense moments
left on the cutting room floor you have
the basic idea in place and then you
just kind of
riff and go off and have a little fun
and you know and i think the version
that got released was actually the clean
version
yeah yeah there's the other version
where betty's much more nasty i think
she's like sharpening the bone of some
orphan about to stab me with it or
something i don't know betty is kind of
a one-of-a-kind person i think she's you
know she's
insanely funny and it has an ability to
work blue humor that you know you just
never expect from a woman of her age
and how does this national treasure
spend their 99th birthday
here's what betty exclusively told e.t
quote what am i doing for my birthday
running a mile each morning has been
curtailed by covid
and as for visitors betty says she's
quote
feeding the two ducks who come to visit
me every day
well let me tell you how she got the
nickname lt greg
no ten years after the proposal
premiered
ryan gave e.t his favorite memory
from working with the comedy legend you
know my fate one of my favorite memories
of betty white is her last day of
shooting on the proposal she's walking
out the door
and the crew is just giving her this
insane standing ovation
and she sort of raises her hand and she
has the best exit i've ever seen for any
entertainer she was like this is the
most fun i've ever had and they all went
oh and she went
standing up and then walked out of the
room and it just was the best it was
like
she invented the mic drop before the mic
dropped
[Music]